so I am build me and I'm a full-time
lecturer here and and I actually when I
heard Miki was speaking I asked to
introduce him and so it's a real honor
to be introducing Miki
he is the truest American icon of
fashion casual fashion and retailing and
he's also been a bit of a friend to me
and a role model for creativity and
leadership for just under 20 years now
Miki and I have something in common
which you won't guess we both went to
high school in the Bronx and he went to
Bronx High School in science which if
you're from New York knows that that
means that at 14 or 15 Miki was a very
smart young man who started who studied
very hard after college he apprenticed
at three of New York's great department
stores Abraham & Straus Macy's and
Bloomingdale's and when we were in the
waiting room he told us that he hated
his first 10 years of work at 36 he was
hired by an tailor which was the first
fashion chain that he led and soon
transformed it in 1983 you joined the
gap gap to join Inc where he at that
point was a few gap stores where you
could buy records and Levi's and he
turned it into America's first great
casual apparel chain he later turned
around a small set of stores called
Banana Republic and turned it into the
Banana Republic you know today created
Gap Kids and then created inbuilt Old
Navy which was really the first fashion
value chain in our country he was
president Gap Inc from 1987 to 1985 and
he was CEO until he left in 2002 in 2003
he became director chair and CEO of
j.crew which was then quite a moribund
brand instead of apparel he took it to a
very strong turn around and took that
tired and focused brand and turned it
into the very vital and successful two
billion dollar chain that is today in
addition he has been a director of Apple
for 19 since 1999 and though Steve Jobs
isn't with us with us anymore you could
have charged admission I'm sure to
conversations between Mickey and Steve I
too I more than anybody else if you look
around the room Mickey Drexler is the
reason almost all of you are dressed the
way you are every kaki every piece of
denim every shirt every sweater was
either created by Mickey or one of his
people or reshaped or recolored in some
important way before I turn it over to
Mickey I'm going to share just a few
brief personal observations I was at
McKinsey for thirty years and only so I
can position Mickey against them I will
mention that amongst the CEOs I serve
were Bill Gates Steve Ballmer Steve Jobs
albeit when he was it next John Chambers
Jim Coulter TPG Katherine Graham punch
souls burger Howard Lester who was the I
don't think he call himself this the
Mickey Drexler of William Sonoma and
several others who were also excellent
leaders but don't have the brand name
panache and so my introduction to Mickey
is that he was and is at his best and
even at his average the most creative
inspiring smart and I might add the most
demanding of all of them and easily the
most fun creative inspiring smart and
demanding his ability to understand
consumers to see color shape and texture
to which most of us would be completely
blind to understand lifestyle indeed the
mindset of each successive generation
this is truly distinctive
well known but he was and is also a
great businessman and a leader while he
was no accountant by any means
I never heard Mickey come up with a
fashion idea that structurally was not
ready to make a lot of money what's the
most volume of an item you've ever
ordered well gee I'd have to think about
that but a million Oh easily yeah ten
million well it's a long story but you
just camille yes so hundreds of
thousands I mean just imagine deciding
that you know next spring absolutely
hundreds of thousands millions of
dollars are those sweaters but it takes
you know there's a story about how it
starts oh okay guys moving outside okay
no I got to finish the compliment okay
go ahead but you weren't an accountant
but he always knew how to price goods
and remember he is called the great
merchant Prince and a merchant above all
knows how to make money now in my career
I had no thrill greater than spending
two hours with Mickey in the first Old
Navy store in Manhattan as he went
around and toured it and looked at every
object every business process every
piece of apparel there and the way you
could see that he could see and
understand and integrate all the
elements of fashion retailing and to do
it with the most engaging monologue that
you could ever hear so with great
personal and general enthusiasm on
behalf of the business school I welcome
Mickey Drexler
what was beautiful you know I was a
little concerned about this being taped
but now I'm very happy after that
introduction bill and I he didn't say we
go way back we fought a lot he was
actually was a gap for many years off
and on and he was really part of the
team and too long too many arguments and
too many disagreements that I even care
to think about but it's really nice to
see him here today and that was probably
the best introduction I've ever had
thank you very much that was really nice
I don't have an agenda a set a speech I
asked my hosts and hostesses what I'd
like what I should talk about and every
time I said something like I didn't like
my first 10 years of life in business
they don't say that when there's no
perfect job oh say that oh I didn't
learn much for most of my bosses oh say
that the the way I learned to buy goods
by the way was interesting this bill
reminded me and I don't have hours
tonight but I was a young baby buyer
blooming those was my first job
Bloomingdale's after school and ended up
buying well this doesn't know if it
sounds like a lot and how many of you
were actually in retailing or worked in
retailing raise your hands so not a lot
anyone I work with here I know there's
two or three people that Stanford
undergraduate one whose mom works here
and one embarrass you works at Stanford
and someone I met in the store today
where are you whoever works at j.crew
now raise your hands for full disclosure
they didn't show up okay that's good
they said they'd be here anyway my first
big buy was actually at Bloomingdale's
where I had a fight with the whole line
of command up into the CEO about buying
a t-shirt that I wanted to buy more than
they've ever purchased before but I kind
of learned mostly on my own about being
a merchandiser and being a business
person and learning from people who who
maybe didn't teach you buddy told me how
not to do what are they taught me how to
be argumentative and I always like to
argue I argued bill over many many
things over the years and and I learned
over time to kind of follow my own
internal judgment now at your stage in
life you don't follow the internal
judgment as much as one does when they
get older more wiser make many mistakes
in your life and business
but at some point now and especially now
where I love what I do and he didn't say
I was fired by the way which I don't
know he knew that very well because he's
probably part of the reason I was fired
Kinsey comes in you know McKenzie comes
in they say oh I think it's time for a
new CEO you know what happens so right
he told me to get out and by the way I
was trying to get out because it's
because it's no fun running a company
that doesn't have much growth left and
mostly in America in my opinion
everything I say is the opinion of its
personal editorial here in fact they
went on the loudspeaker today I was
flying out from New York this morning
and I said everyone says Sky Bowl is a
must-see
I said personal opinion is the most
overrated to long movie I've ever seen
in my life and so tacky and then I said
by the way flight got great reviews the
movie I said it was a horrible movie and
what airplane flies upside down and
doesn't crash so I've learned that the
world doesn't have the kind of quality
it needs to have that they keep they
keep and I mean this they keep referring
to old things to try to make them new I
saw the preview of watching sky ball and
Saturday was die hard again and you know
the world one thing being on the board
of 14 years with Steve who I miss
tremendously is the fact that you move
forward you figure out where things are
going and then you make a very you base
your risk and investment on upside and
downside when I buy goods and we buy
goods it's the same thing so I started
my career with Bloomingdale's why
because I got a job offer at a and asked
where I had a summer MBA job they
offered me ten and a half thousand
dollars a year I'll never forget this
and these are all little signals about
your life and about where you go so I
recommended a friend of mine who was a
finance guy from from my class and they
offered him 11 thousand a year so I'm
speaking to him and I said he offered
you 11 me 10 and a half thousand they
knew me I worked there for three months
I was furious and pissed off and to me
it said a lot more than the $500 which
was important when you don't have money
and then 500 probably worth 3,000 a year
or whatever it is today and I said I'm
not going to work here I
went to work at Bloomingdale's thank God
and Bloomingdale's n was kind of
becoming what it became and now it's not
any morges most department stores at
discount stores to me today
but I think it's you start to figure out
and learn from all those little things
you see in your life and then I always
quote Steve on this from his Stanford
speech and see I like to take credit for
it but since I'm at Stanford I can't say
you connected that's backwards because
you'll probably know I don't know but
anyone know that that's what he said in
this speech you can so I use that all
the time it's very true about life you
can't figure it out at the beginning
stages as you're in but you figure it
out and you look at where your career
goes or where your life goes or other
things go and then you connect it you
kind of connected backwards so I went to
work at Bloomingdale's I was very lucky
to work for a woman in those days women
were like sometimes not seriously taken
but the Gress I work with eight out of
ten women on their senior executive
level eight of ten of them are women
because I actually like working with
women more so no offense against men
because we have some men in finance and
some men and merchandising so on and so
forth but I learned from Katie Murphy
may she rest in peace who died at a much
too young age about you buy what you
like you figure out what's happening
color is important style is important
and all that's important now if you kind
of look at it same thing with Apple by
the way it was always the same factors
about being creative figuring out where
the puck is going as Wayne Gretzky said
so
so my first few years I love my first
year and a half at Bloomingdale's and
then I became an executive I was a buyer
merchants you buy the goods you argued
in the sense I bought 30,000 t-shirts
they wanted to buy 6,000 and you're
figurin if a day in February you can
sell in cold weather and this is East
Coast only X amount of t-shirt so what
does that mean for a full day or a week
or a month in May or June it's
complicated so I won't get into detail
on that I spent I spend six years at
Bloomingdale's didn't really I can say
didn't really well some of my bosses
might hear this they roll nice and some
missile friends I didn't really learn
anything other than what I kept teaching
myself what Katie in the early year or
two would teach me when to work and then
Macy spent a year and a half here and
said this is really not good and suck up
is important what
you wear is important I think that's
true in a lot of corporations today and
then I went to a and s and that was it I
spent four years there and I got a job
offer at at Ann Taylor and I wasn't
going to take it but a friend of mine
said I'd rather you go as he was ten
years older much more successful I said
I have a problem was twelve years old or
in fact and he was kind of a role model
we don't talk anymore by the way he just
is one of those people that after while
you had enough of him but in those days
he gave me enough information he said I
would take that job in a second you're
running a company you have an
opportunity and I went to Ann Taylor
when I was 35 and spent three or four
years they were taken over by a big bad
company within six months allied so on
and so forth that's my story I went to
gap I moved out to California and want
to ever leave New York and then spend
eighteen years there got fired for
whatever reason I thought it was the
best thing to ever happen and been a
j.crew since having a lot of fun
building an important team partnering
with TPG and Leonard green we went
public
first we parted with GPG we went public
and then we went private last March of
2011 and that's where we are that takes
you through my entire career now any
questions okay cuz I'd rather just tell
you what ask me what you want to learn I
did say I think and it's the individual
not the degree and I think here is a
powerful important group of people who
get a great education great networking
so on and so forth but people I admire
it's not and I'm not a big one for test
scores I don't care where people
graduate from college I think taking a
test and see I got into science I took a
test and I did well it had nothing by
the way thank God I went there because
if I didn't go there I would've went to
what is now ranked as the worst high
school in the Bronx and I started to see
kids a lot smarter especially the
scientists I was always good in math and
you do need math to run a business but
but I was very lucky I went there
because it exposed me to a whole new
world outside of my zip code 100
whatever it was in the Bronx and that
was important so that's who I am to have
a lot of fun doing what I do
it's never a straight line upwards it's
always a lot of angst you get knocked
down a lot you have to come back you get
knocked down
and people I know where success will
have this will keep moving forward and
not be well some of them are arrogant
about it but after while they might earn
the arrogance but in my business every
single day I was flying out here this
morning I said you know I've been coming
out here for 10 years since I moved back
to New York same trip every three months
to Mars and Apple board meeting I'm
going the Stanford Shopping Center I'm
going to San Francisco Center I said
I've been doing this for so long and
every single day I learned more I
learned what's wrong what's right what
we need to do better how do I learn it
by talking to store people talking to
customers and having very curious might
and surrounding yourselves by people who
I have to words get it very hard but if
they get it they get it and if they
don't they don't and no one will teach
you I don't think of the business school
what get it means it's in the eyes of
the beholder I interview everyone in the
company now who's not an IT I know
finials in technology even though I'm on
the board of Apple I know nothing and I
don't know what they say and what they
mean so but I interview I into everyone
else in the company because it's very
important I have an obligation to like
someone and like their future and
especially in merchandising and
marketing and and all those things that
a customer sees I see it and and I have
an opinion on everything right or wrong
and then I want people who can disagree
and say what they think okay questions
yes I never said it like that okay well
you know here's Israel I feel about
business school I think and I have weird
experience in retail and I don't know if
I'm right or wrong and by the way I
think the job market is extraordinarily
difficult today and I also think and I
don't know if this is right if you live
and work out here go to school out here
you see a little different view of the
world from what we might see cuz out
here you have all these young
billionaires running around a lot of
them run very overvalued companies a lot
of them get the right jobs I'm sure some
of you were here maybe you made a lot of
money and you just hanging out for a few
years but I think the real world is not
what's in Northern California so I don't
know if that applies to Stanford or not
I have happened to be someone who
ever went to fancy schools which is why
sometimes I'm angry at fancy school
people you know it's just natural but I
also think that the people I know who
are very successful and success to find
is not being the CEO of a big
corporation because I think a lot of
CEOs get there because they're good at
sea owing they're good with boards of
directors I know a lot of CEOs today not
that I know them personally but I look
at their business as I say they
shouldn't be employed I also think that
retailers should run retail companies I
think car men or woman should run car
companies and I think so on and so forth
I'm always a little astounded when
someone comes in to run a company who
has no expertise in that category I've
been going to school now for 3540 years
on doing what I do and trying to keep
learning and being focused and and I
don't think a lot of companies or maybe
CEOs realize that first of all if you're
a CEOs is practical you all want to how
many of you want to be a CEO here raise
your heads I'm curious the truth raise
your hands the truth of a small company
of a big company so when you get that
job and Bill lived with all of them in
most cases and he named a group that
didn't get there this way I think you
get the private jet trust me it's really
a great perk and most most no I don't I
I had one a gap I have my own now so
it's not because I didn't want to have
to have a company thing you get that you
get overpaid like crazy you get
long-term compensation which is always
more than you earn you get stock win or
lose the company
you win on the restricted stock deals
right because it's worth whatever so why
give up the job if you have five or
seven years tenure and you and you and
you retire wealthy as opposed to people
who take risk who have their own money
we have 18 people a j.crew I can do this
at Gap we have 18 people who have cash
in the business I put 1/3 of my value we
went profit but one-third in the
business so I bought 10% of the company
because I think there's nothing like and
it's all relative because when I was
younger I had no money and by the way I
didn't have any money I was 44 years old
so I want you to know that I had no
money until I was 40 for now on Silicon
Valley it's no money until you're 28 but
but the rest of us don't grow up that
way
unless you inherit it and some of us in
this room I'm sure have inherited it but
the fact of the matter is you get those
jobs you don't want to take the risks
necessary this is all my opinion to
build to invest to take the risks of
maybe losing your job I look at the auto
companies in America maybe someone will
start to pay attention to the cars and
what they look like one of them I think
is doing that in America the other two
irrelevant what the cars look like it's
it's an accountant who's running it's
just that get a great car designer like
John hire Johnny I've had Apple I should
hope that doesn't happen but get a great
car designer to design a car you know
how many they'll sell of that car but no
it's all a matter of and most of the
cars look alike to me on the road I
remember the days where cars were unique
they were different or just do something
that's not just black white and gray do
a cool color I went visited Ford Motor
Company we started Old Navy which is by
the way named after a bar in Paris the
Board of Directors hated the name but if
you name your child or even I'm getting
a dog in two weeks easily she lives out
here we named it Dorothy no one's going
to tell me it's a better good name
Dorothy the dog same thing when you
start a company no one's going to tell
you if the company is a good at bad name
we hired to naming companies a gap
because someone didn't like the name Old
Navy what's the difference you put a
name on a person or on a business and it
becomes what that name is but in fact so
so you have to figure out where the
business is going to go and you have to
take a position most CEOs today I don't
think and Bill would know this better or
willing to take the risk to bet
something on the company and and who
have risk at stake you look at one
retailer I won't mention it out there
today it's a little Stanley or what's
going on see is the part I can't talk
about because it's because he's a friend
of mine so I won't talk about that
anyway what so your questions on MBAs no
no your question is on MBAs the fact of
the matter is it's who you are not what
your degree says and I no friend of mine
moved from Indianapolis to New York he's
very successful shopping center
developer the biggest in fact and here's
the deal we had lunch Friday and he's
saying I don't know what to do in New
York every kid starts and this is how
many of you from New York Manhattan
manehattan how old we started taking the
SAT lessons $4,000 a week or something
right
he says I'm from Indianapolis you can
figure out who it is and he said my kids
junior and they're starting to take the
tests and in New York they start his
freshman it's it's a race to do well on
tests which is not an indication of how
successful you'll be in life now most
people who get into schools test well or
they have wealthy parents let's call it
what it is or they have philanthropic
parents so they know someone so I so
it's not against MBAs well it's true
right no it's true so I'm not against
MBAs I'm all for people who make a
difference and a willing to have some
vision take a risk and it's not easy
when you're young and I call all of you
younger some much older at 40 years old
you're probably not as young anymore but
so that's that's it it's not against
MBAs just people who have reasonable
expectations and don't think as they
have a degree it means that going places
now I know works in banking I assume
it's very important in banking I think
in McKinsey it's important right and but
I think common sense logic and I call
the most important things I see is IQ
and EQ and street smarts and an instinct
so and it takes time to develop that
okay what other questions keep going
yes you reportedly had quite an
explosive personal personality and
apparently you sort of you know
countdown at j.crew and Steve Jobs you
know had the same issue and we're taught
here in the business school you know
this very humanistic approach to
management where you have to you know
take care of or all your edges not to be
in any way you know violent other people
I was wondering what are you have to be
what did you say violent no no I didn't
say aggressive I'm sorry my English
probably no not too
and so the question was what are your
thoughts on this like transformational
CEOs like Steve Jobs and like you are
transformational because of or despite
of their explosive personality well
first of all I would ask you I don't
know what explosive means here was
already defined Steve and I are
different very different may he rest in
peace were very different personalities
and I admired him more than any business
person in the world and remember what
Steve did and no one says it's the last
seven years of his life he was fighting
a disease that was probably fatal and
and you watched what he did and it was
extraordinary you know what I consider I
think it's all not being full of [ __ ]
that's so if you call that explosive if
you look at someone and say what I think
or you look at the goods first of all
the goods speak the ideas speak and if
someone didn't how many people actually
say what they think you read earnings
reports I see all these earning reports
and stop giving me BS just say it wasn't
the weather just say maybe we didn't
have the right goods maybe we didn't
have the right the right team and of
course you have the pressures of quarter
court I don't believe I was explosive I
could not tolerate people who didn't get
it I was short on on patience but if
you're running a big company you must be
short on patience the winners whoever
said I was explosive I probably fired
right no I don't know who was it but the
winners respond to honest passion in a
business I'd like to see those guys that
I say they're all men who run the car
companies they're always so cool about
it you know they're always here's the
earnings here's this or this that and
the other thing there's nothing wrong
with showing passion by the way most of
us who are like that don't do well in
companies I didn't do as well in a
department store business because first
I couldn't stand having to play a role
but your first look my first 10 years I
had to make a living I never could
afford not to make a living because it
just wasn't in the cards so you had to
be right you had to play it right and
you can't be explained and I don't think
I was explosive Steve was purely
emotional and wasn't always the most
polite guy in the world and by the way
at the board meetings
it wasn't that easy being with Steve but
at the end of the day when I look back
and I connected that's backwards Wow
you saw the world as it was I think
young people love people get mad who are
passionate and who are honest and don't
sit back and don't care that much so I I
defined all that as a critically
important issue in people run successful
companies now if you're a corporate CEO
you've all worked for them I've worked
for them in the beginning they are
really cool they don't sweat they come
down the escalator in the store like
this and they don't care that much and
they don't say hello a lot of the time
and and everyone has feelings and I
always say look if this is the way I am
that's the way you have and by the way I
think as long as you're respectful so
I've always been respectful but in my
early days when you're in your 30s or
40s you're running a company that's
being drained like gap you have to get
mad the ship's going down at j.crew we
came there with seven or fifty million
dollars in debt and you're there and you
have to save the company and you have to
take care of the people who don't meet
your standards and I think most
companies have a very hard time firing
the higher-ups who in fact should be
fired because it's not them that's being
hurt it's all the people underneath them
who are not respecting them or quit
because the boss ain't great so but how
do you transform you get older you get a
little richer you don't really you know
and you're cooler about things but but
that's what happens and I think I
respect people who just it's a passion
thing for me all right what else and
turning around j.crew what stories did
you tell internally and externally to
motivate people it's kind of drive the
change what what stories did I tell ya
the company's story how do you remove
eight people well you know it's kind of
connected to this at some point in your
life you realize the people you want
working for you just want to hear what
it's like I love I got my review at
Apple on the board the other day I got a
call I'll say this I you know I got a
that you know we have these reviews I
got so I had not the chairman art
Levinson who I love
but Bill Campbell calls me on the phone
two weeks ago he says you're doing a
great job you know we have these
self-evaluation he says but and the but
was your on you do email during the
board meeting and I said you know bill
it's taking twelve or thirteen years for
someone to say that it sounds like I'm
so happy you said it and he was dancing
around it I like the feedback he used to
give me feedback about me being a CEO it
I'd gap now gap was a particularly
interesting dynamic family involvement
and you're always tightrope walking here
or there but I find that if you tell
someone where they stand
especially now I'm older I got a review
older I then sent an email to the board
and I said thank you for the feedback I
was waiting for someone to stop me I'm
obsessive about getting back on my
emails but it's what happens someone
tells you what to do and when you're
younger and I was older it's fine you
listen you absorb it's not personal its
business and as long as it teaches you
and motivates you the story I told
outside and inside was exactly the same
story now I've been through it a number
of times the more you do this the better
you get I've been practicing my craft as
a CEO for 33 years so when you practice
your craft and you get better at it and
you get better you realize people put a
premium on honesty directness and
success and one thing you have to worry
about if you're me going into new job is
that lip-reading too much and the last
thing you wanted people to lip read but
it's it's a style it's a finesse it's
how you do it but it's always direct the
best thing is be direct and let them
know you care as much as they do when
you're there to support them and I
always blame myself first for every
mistake and and if you do that by the
way I like people who blame themselves
first for every mistake they make
because they care the most I know if
that answers it but there's the same
story always because you can't make up
different stories now if you're a public
company's CEO and I see this going on a
lot some of them tell stories that I
look into and I say wait the the quarter
was but the other thing that's kind of
odd is if you make expectations the
press makes it sound like you're doing
well or they lost 30 million instead of
40
oh they beat expectations and you read
the thing say wait they lost money that
doing horrible but it's what we deal
with in the public markets it'll never
change yes obviously you were very
familiar with TPG Judy her previous
experience but what was your rationale
for and good to go private second time
and how are you going to create values
for your private equity investors well
um the the reason for the buyout is now
because there was a lot of one there was
one person who kept writing bad things
but I'll never forget it but you don't
probably don't know who it is anyway
Hawaii who have since kind of apologized
to me anyway the reason was that TPG and
Leonard green thought that the company
was undervalued now when you run a
public company especially in
merchandising in fashion the stocks I
always say you know they have what is it
called they they say it's a what's that
thing in growth a hockey stick growth
that's not like go to where the pucks
going everything's hockey terms it's
like you've got no company goes like
this and retailing it's more like a w in
a sense when the stock went from we went
public at 20 and I'm just just
background public at 20 up to 57 down to
8 when not 2008 up to 50 down to 20 up
to 30 TPG and Leonard Green said you
know this is a coming with a great
future and Wall Street could not care
less about long term I don't care what
you say it's trading it's it's all that
machine trading or whatever it is it's
hedge funds trading no one cares except
the management have come you owns the
company and whether you own it or not
you care passionately about the long
term because you could compromise any
business in the short term so they've
made an offer there's a lot of talk
about it we got sued immediately which
happens every time were you in the
business of like private equity or
anything
tbg see there you go gave it away
that's called EQ okay so so anyway and
they made an offered 4550 then it came
down to 43 50 no one else offered so
they bought X percent I bought 10% and
the shareholders by the way what's
interesting you know this the
David deals announced all your
shareholders sell the stock the only
ones holding the stock are speculative
buyers
no one cares less about except for a
nickel or a dime etc etc but the
rationale was they thought to quote
Leonard green company we're in the third
inning of a nine inning game they felt
it was great potential we're relatively
a small company in the world and they a
lot of faith in the management and for
me the most important thing was keeping
the management together and us having
investments in the company how do we
create value it's very simple you grow
your earnings in a high-quality way over
time and having been with TPG fruit now
a long time and they were directors of
the company I felt they were going to be
great partners I didn't want to take on
the debt but I felt very comfortable
because one of my friends said to me you
will worry as much with debt or without
that and I said well then we're going to
do the deal and that's why we did it
creating value is purely creating
earnings profit and a good future for
the company in a my leadership
perspectives class we have a lot of CEOs
come through and they say a good leader
will ultimately make themselves
replaceable
whether through hiring I don't believe
that by the way I don't believe it with
us in the US yeah yeah there was no
investment with Leonard you know without
Mickey Drexler
there's no j.crew without making tracks
um well here's where I think I don't
believe that that's who said that the
leadership class that's not your class
bill is they don't know
by the way I don't really believe that I
also don't believe companies go on
forever I'm not making a political
staying by saying I'm not sure we should
support companies or the banks that go
bankrupt I think companies get too big
and they lose their edge and they become
total bureaucracies so if I look at the
bank's JP Morgan or Goldman this so big
that they're so none quick there's no
Matt look that when JP Morgan ago and
they do those things you think the CEOs
know what the hell is going on now gloy
Blanc finds a friend of mine I don't
know if they know what's going on in
those large companies I find most CEOs
above it all because they have this huge
bureaucracy they're running I don't
think most leaders are in fact
replaceable now the fact is if you look
at great companies they don't last
forever nor should they
but what happens in retail now there's
international so to speak the cost of
money is nothing you can go on a you
know more about this than I do you can
go on managing a business because it
doesn't cost it is that there's no risk
I mean money's really cheap but I don't
think that company's succession planning
I always thought even when I was a young
guy in the business I always just to
laugh cuz you know it's like six plan
succession from Pablo Picasso okay plan
succession now I said publicly you know
Tim Cook is following Steve Jobs and by
the way I think in any business it takes
five years to do your job well as a CEO
and I've been doing this for ten years I
can't believe it's ten years and every
day we're building and building and
building it never stops now succession
planning in a case like woohoo
like I stay Lord is an interesting case
I think they did well they had family
now they have a professional manager I
for me and by the way we each have our
own mission in a business for us its
quality its creativity its taking care
of the customers in a nice way a lot of
companies out there don't care so much
about that they care quarter-to-quarter
but but it's a long philosophical
discussion I don't believe in it because
I've been listening to it for 40 years
now and I look at companies and I don't
know where you can say there's been a
seamless fantastic person
take over maybe I don't know about the
banking business it's probably easy to
do the banking business and it is to do
the art business if you're a painter if
your retailer has a sense it's probably
more difficult to have succession Costco
which is a great company probably is
less difficult because I think the two
founders they did a spectacular job it's
a great company I think it depends on
each individual company I know there are
no rules and regulations and any of this
stuff that people say and you know look
at General Electric was it a bank I
never knew what Six Sigma was ever does
anyone know what Six Sigma is you might
know I never understood it my whole life
and I listened to the Six Sigma and I
listened to Andy Grove once at a talk
Andy made sense Six Sigma I didn't
understand so if I don't understand
something I say then it's not right but
but it's part of by the way being
logical and not being intimidated by
what you hear is the right thing to do
it takes a long time to really say what
you think in fact I never would have
said Skyfall was a crappy movie now I
can say whatever I want to say you know
and I think with CEO succession but you
tell me give me the great examples of
CEO succession this place is named for
Phil Knight I don't think there's been
great succession there Phil Knight who I
didn't know person it was an
extraordinary business builder so I
don't know I think things change time
will tell time will tell and and and
what you do what Steve Jobs does you'd
hate to follow him into a job let's face
it's much easier to take over a company
that's not doing well you know what I
mean instead of one that plays the game
that way time will tell on that and it
will be who knows how much time okay who
someone was put you're in charge of the
questions okay good
I was wondering if you could talk about
the potential that you think the fashion
industry could play in addressing some
of the biggest issues facing the world
such as poverty and have you seen any
exciting business models or
interventions from brands in the fashion
industry that are addressing these
issues or have some promise there well
you know that's not my paygrade because
I think in terms of addressing poverty I
wouldn't even know where to begin
because you can say fashion industry car
industry any industry you can say the
values in America you could say the tax
system you could say sharing and I don't
want it to me it's it's not it's not the
fashion industry's job except to
increase employment and increase the
economy have thethethe tax system being
fair why should private equity pay 50
percent or hedge funds I don't have an
answer it's really not my paygrade but I
think and by the way I think it's
critical I don't think anyone pays much
attention that or how about education
because poverty comes perhaps from lack
of education and but I think the world
is in a place that maybe it needs to be
changed in that regard I think the
priorities have to be changed in America
you saw the campaign and whatever but I
don't know how the fashion industry can
do that without the world changing its
we're just a very tiny piece of it I
don't know if that answers it but TFA
what about it so well no I'm on the
board of Teach for America but trying to
get funding even for Teach for America I
love Teach for America I love Wendy Kopp
and and for me for me personally my wife
and I we support poor kids who need an
education
I identify a little with that growing up
in the Bronx but I think education today
is the most politicized thing in the
world now I'm not an expert but but
you're dealing with lots of issues that
maybe people afraid to stand up on I
think the priorities are so miss spent
in America you know so rich people pay
more taxes big F and deal right and I
don't know Bill would know better if in
fact having rich people pay more taxes
means that it's not going to grow the
economy as much so people can't buy 50
million-dollar paintings I don't
understand that but it's not my paygrade
all right so lately we've seen quite a
few brands and retailers that have begun
and exist entirely online so is there
anything to talk a little about
oh yeah I'd love to well online to me is
a hugely disruptive force by the way I
never heard of until today
uber taxi you guys all know about it
you know what I've been saying in my
business and but if I'm going too long
and it's just cut me off because
whatever what I've been saying in my
industry when I was a buyer at
Bloomingdale's there was no online with
discount stores and when you bought a
brand let's say what is Nike or whatever
I bought women's sportswear and swimwear
and t-shirts if you bought a brand and
it was at the discount store down the
road you had to was our policy meet
their price now fast-forward 30 plus
years online is disrupting the world as
it is right now and I find that and and
when I was when I went to gap and sakta
Dan Taylor in 19 I went to Ann Taylor 19
it's a long time ago 1980 yeah
1980 we started to create I took a model
of Benetton and Brooks Brothers Brooks
Brothers had the same parent company as
we did allied stores disaster no it was
actually a Garfinkel Brooks Brothers and
I said gee here's Brooks Brothers they
don't have to worry about carrying any
brands at people marking down and I
don't know you know you connected that's
backwards
I don't know if in my head it was wow
they had 16% pre-tax earnings and it was
again I it was connecting it backwards
said well I want to be like Brooks
Brothers because I don't have to worry
about buying all the brands at a
discount and then it wasn't like it is
today you go online right now Best Buy
probably won't be in business I don't
think but I don't know what you all
think about that so so for me my whole
career is based on exclusivity or
controlling your distribution now Steve
Jobs when I first met Steve 15 years ago
he said I want to be like Gap and have
my own stores I thought he was nuts
because I knew we did it because at Ann
Taylor we started to go to our own label
and Taylor studio because I didn't want
to have what everyone else had and it's
happened dramatically today different I
mean the world has moved forward that
way so much where everyone has the same
goods
and then I went to gap and a gap they
had 20 different names leave Isis
one-third of the company's volume and
Levi's was low margin and everyone
carried Levi's everyone discounted I
didn't know any better I was a young guy
I came in to run this public company the
earnings always drop and I did say that
to the guy we were talking about today
that when you take over a company the
first year earnings going to drop at
least half they forecasted flat earnings
the earnings will drop because you're
cleaning out old inventory and you're
betting andrey betting the company so so
with GAAP we went to GAAP only we had 20
different names in the survey said this
by the way I don't do research on what
the customer wants I'm sure some of you
you're in the research business I don't
know if you are not I find it no one
will tell you where the puck is going
they'll always tell you where it is I
went to Ford Motor Company in 1994 and
visited with the then CEO side a friend
on the board we want to do a little Navy
truck they brought out these very cool
trucks they said the customers told us
they didn't like them and then they were
telling us colors that the customers did
not like now I'm thinking this is
bizarre anyway GAAP we had GAAP brand
and we controlled it completely
Levi's finally said they didn't want to
sell us I was all nervous I said fine
you know something is opportunity in the
midst of adversity
Steve came when I met Steve and whenever
this was he said I want to open up Apple
stores because I can't depend upon
distribution of my product at Best Buy
who's still in business and named the
rest of them are all gone and he
couldn't control his image he couldn't
control anything here comes online now
you go online and I do this as a matter
of practice and everyone in our company
does this now if there's a brand you
want to pay the best price Amazon ships
really well cosmetics America ships it
well target ships all of its in the box
I called the CEO of one of my former
companies I was a director and I said by
the way your goods are one-third more
than they are Target or Amazon oh we we
didn't catch that brand you go look at a
brand today I think they're all
commodities every single brand is a
commodity
you got gilt you got all the discounts
t.j.maxx
raus stores are all selling goods at
this count so what do I think of online
it's a huge disruptive force just like
uber taxi which I only a friend of mine
I flew out with a friend of mine and he
was telling me that he has an uber taxi
app I never heard of that my life he
says it's unbelievable I have them out
here I guess they have them in New York
and there's so many disruptive forces in
the world so what I think of online it's
going to keep changing the landscape
dramatically and I think it's going to
start to put a lot of people at risk in
the business and it is right now because
I don't ever want to be in a business
where I have to wake up every day
worrying about someone selling it for a
better price because I know for me it's
not what I want to do and I wouldn't be
the best at it
so now you got Amazon who maybe they can
afford to have a 200 multiple and not
make any money whatever it is they just
announced last week to going after the
peril business they're opening studios
in New York so I think it's one of the
biggest disruptive forces that in our
business and I don't know about other
business people aren't paying that much
attention to or they're not admitting to
it we go online and we buy a lot of
stuff and my wife in cosmetics or
whatever else she might buy and it's a
matter of practice you shop right here
you find out the best price it comes in
the same box it gets delivered there's
no servicing when I ask my fellow
they're not really friends in mine they
all don't like me that much in the
department store business because I
don't like the department store business
because I say what do they do better
than other people and all this stuff
they sell is available somewhere else
you look at every designer name every
brand name and you will see it sold at a
discount it's hard not to find it at a
discount so I don't know how long it's
going to take who knows but it's a
hugely disruptive force and you probably
know a lot more about that because you
probably live more online than I do but
we're very sensitive to that and that's
why we don't want to build anything
that's available a lesser price because
at some point it's going to catch up and
bite you hard I probably left some
things out there but I don't know so
that's what I think okay who else is
next
two things first arm fashion is such a
small part you said and big problems
actually I'm sure you wear fashion is
actually the second most polluting in
the industry that's most polluting in
this matter world and not aware after
oil and gas how do what survey tells you
that well I think it's just this you
know something I don't believe it until
you show me the real affection let's
walk through the whole value chain
cotton growth I mean I'd rather take it
for this purpose it pesticides ok
chemicals cause dyes all that good so
there's huge potential we can do in the
fashion industry however my question was
borne out to what you did padega in
terms of Grambling because I think the
way you reshape the gap but now also
j.crew j.crew has come to a point you
look at a male aisle you look at the
website you look at any piece and it
just looks consistent you know it's
j.crew and i feel like how do you do
that in a company that big that goes
through so many consumer touch points
how do you really good question point of
view that you have succeeded to refine
so well you know it's a really good
question and isn't it's really not that
big the company if you came and visited
us you will see that's just i don't
think it's that big and i think the
focus and this is what a CEO does see I
used to get criticized for micromanaging
Steve is a terrible micro manager I look
at everything you see and if I don't see
it and it passes by me and I don't like
it I'm furious because I I didn't
partner in it I saw something online
today I wasn't aware that we did and it
drove me a little crazy but it's if you
if if you hire what well I have a loud
speaker by the way so Ike wherever I am
I call out all over the world and and by
the way it's is a thousand people at 770
I think every company shouldn't be
allowed to have walls in their offices
and they should have loudspeakers
because I'm on the phone all day and if
I go into Stanford today or San
Francisco Center and I called out the
fact that I thought the necklace
is whatever and this is whatever but I
am a micromanager on the finest detail
on what you see as a customer then by
the way it's not just me Jenna Lyons
Diego Scottie Tracy the team you must
have a sense of people who get it and
understand the vibe of the brand that's
really really important and it's it
takes a lot of work to get the people
who kind of move with you and get it and
feel it but I say whatever customer sees
is really my job in their job but but we
go through every every email every if
you look at the catalog I should have
had the catalogs here I don't the brand
new catalog we look at those as we're
publishing a magazine every week every
style every outfit every cover and by
the way we screw up we screwed up why
we're private cuz we screwed up two
years ago on it was too late by the time
I look at the catalog it's pretty much
there I looked at the cover of July 2010
and I prayed I said holy [ __ ] we're in
trouble and we all know they'll never
forget there's this woman lying down
looking very weird and undulate and and
that's a really big issue but you do it
because you know how to focus out all
unimportant things in your life I don't
spend time with IT people I spend time
in the stores like crazy I look at
everything vision when I look at all the
styles in the company and I do that and
I love what I do but it's it's what your
job is as a CEO if the guys who ran I
say the men they need some good woman in
the car industry for style if the guys
who were in the car cummings looked at
the design of those cars and said why do
they do this oh but look at the movie
industry how do they allow those movies
to go out maybe there's no vision or
maybe they're trying to make the movies
longer and they think they'll get more
business I don't know I'm a big
complaint on Treacher about that stuff
but at the end of the day it's a vision
following it being consistent I haven't
seen Mercedes change that star in a
hundred years I don't know what a GM car
looks like anymore or Chrysler anymore
or a lot of other cars or the Toyota has
that little thing like this or Audi or
BMW or them
me is a very well designed quarry from
the Fiat has the badge its consistency
and advertising and everything else you
do I can answer this for hours but
alright what's so you talked about how
it took you until you were 44 to be 60
at least financially successful well
it's all relative um so maybe 43 I think
was 42 actually good alright then I
don't I still have the check okay go
ahead so a lot of us as a late bloomer
go ahead it's okay a lot of us you
probably don't want to wait until we're
four I know that I know I know
um I know and I think you know a lot of
but you'll have to you have no choice if
you look at it statistically but what's
your name Henry were you from East Coast
yeah I figured okay go ahead it's the
money thing go ahead
my parents they asked you go to this
school at the West Coast you're supposed
to be a billionaire by the time you're
28 and where you're from in New York I'm
from Washington DC okay it's the same
thing um not really go ahead so um you
all could you talk a little bit more
about certain key decisions setbacks key
moments in your life in your career to
making it to where you are today
yeah and potential advice on those of us
who are trying to become Billy okay at
28 versus well if by the way I never
tried to get rich and I'm serious I only
wanted to have a nice car have a home no
see I grew up in the Bronx you know
without a bedroom whatever it's all
relative and and I think that's a really
good question but it's again it's
personally for me because I don't
understand and nor should i what how you
all think today or how my children think
which is different perhaps and I thought
because when I grew up you had to go to
work unless well most people there
weren't that many rich kids around then
you know this you know I was the second
generation whatever my grandparents are
from Poland but I think today don't be
disappointed because you won't be a
billionaire buy you time you twenty or
in this room when I went to college you
say look to the left look to the right
they still say that and not here there
oh I see look to you but but I think one
of the things about in your and you have
a competitive school back east that's
terribly arrogant about this you know
who they are right but for me I had a
different outlook and it wasn't like in
2000 ever forget running gap and all the
cotton Silicon Valley had that bubble
and I'm looking at these and by the way
today also I think the hedge fund wealth
is really out of control
I think it's crazy is there an
improvement see it's kind of how do you
help poverty by having people trade
stocks and not create jobs that's
something that doesn't help I think when
you build things like Google or you know
whatever else gets built Facebook or
great companies that hire a lot of
people that creates jobs personally look
I went to work at Bloomingdale's after
two years had [ __ ] I don't like this
anyway don't trust FOIAs I was making a
living I couldn't quit and by the way
I'm how many how many of you could
afford to quit a job and not work I
don't know how many can she's always
looking for a job when you're working
then I went to Macy's that was a real
disaster I was there three weeks and I
said oh god this is a mistake I didn't
think about it cuz when you have an
economic need you don't have the luxury
of saying oh I'm going to quit and then
I was worried about resume stuff you
didn't want to quit that soon then I
left Macy's I went back to federated
which owned ans I got there and said
this is another mistake then I got
depressed I was always a little anxious
during each day in each job and then I
got a little depressed and said I'm now
34 years old I was making an okay living
until by the way I looked over the desk
and I saw some my cohorts one in
particular was making thirty percent
more than I was because he was hired
from the outside I got [ __ ] furious
and I said if he thinks you know I was
like the ten and a half thousand to the
eleven does those are all points in your
life where you like mistakes and used
some point realized if you're going to
work in companies where they're judging
you incorrectly then you shouldn't be
there and you got to find the right
place to work so I went to work at Ann
Taylor I thought it was a big risk I was
taking I didn't go for a big raise I
went to work I ran a company I learned
on the ground I was very lucky was a
twenty five million dollar company then
my bosses were all one only worried
about his cleaning in Washington DC
Brooks Brothers was base but Garfinkel
Miller roads is based on K Street and
what I'll never forget to go down there
and the president the corporation only
worried about his dry cleaning I swear
to god this is true he'd say to his
assistant did you get my dry cleaning
today this is what he did it was a riot
but they didn't pay attention because
they own the department store here and
there I had we taken over in six months
I stayed for four years not for the
money because there was no such thing as
big stock options and then I had to get
out I wanted to be in New York as I
loved New York City I ended up at Gap
why four that's a whole lot the long
answer but I had setbacks and gap I was
there a year I told my chairman to go F
himself and then I called my wife said
we have no money I didn't say it first
I'm here in New York we don't have a
place to live and I told him you know
the fights I used to have with him right
there's all these friendly lovely fights
or whatever and and we ended up being
great partners by the way my dad because
it was ying and yang
but I could name so many periods in my
life when you get your ass kicked you
don't feel that good and then you got to
follow your vision you got to follow
your path and when you connected that's
backwards you realize you're doing the
right thing but if you if you stay in
your job and you get very comfortable
most of the people I worked with my
equals and peers I really it's a very
small percent of the success ratio as I
measure it is very small because no one
took the risk of taking a position now I
move 3,000 miles away and I paid a big
price for it because I'm a New Yorker by
birth by DNA it's like taking an animal
out of the woods and putting him into a
zoo whatever animals feel I don't know
how they feel but I feel badly for them
you know it was the same thing I had a
terrible transition personally and
professionally into an environment
overlooking 280 and a cemetery and I was
on 57th and 5th in Manhattan trying to
be a big-shot so you pay the price but
you know something it's over the long
term that you make these kinds of
sacrifices and it's never ever easy
especially well it's normally never easy
and don't plan on being a billionaire
and by the way three or four hundred
millions enough
okay that's it so